[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
se enfrían aún más las relaciones entre
Beijing y Washington por cuenta del
sobrevuelo de un globo chino en espacio
aéreo estadounidense el cual según la
Casa Blanca tenía como objetivo espiar
Aunque el gobierno de Pin asegura que
llevaba a cabo una misión de
investigación meteorológica analizaremos
las consecuencias en las relaciones
bilaterales
el gobierno de Australia dijo no a un
megaproyecto minero cerca de la gran
Barrera de coral al considerar que su
desarrollo traería daños irreversibles
al ecosistema de la zona se trata de una
decisión histórica aplaudida por grupos
de ecologistas pues es la primera vez
que se bloquea un proyecto de
explotación de carbón
en Filipinas la piña además de ser uno
de los alimentos más cultivados
consumidos y exportados es una
herramienta fundamental para la
industria textil al punto de generar
millonarias ganancias al año
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático con toda la atención
que se ha generado con el sobrevuelo de
un globo chino en el espacio aéreo de
Estados Unidos recientemente la Casa
Blanca ha señalado que estos globos
hacen parte de un amplio programa de
vigilancia del ejército chino para
obtener información de inteligencia no
solo en su territorio sino en países de
los cinco continentes
Beijing que reconoció como suyo el
artefacto tildo de exagerada la decisión
de Washington de derribarlo y además ha
desmentido que tenga dicho programa de
vigilancia y se ha defendido señalando
que el globo hacía parte de una
investigación meteorológica y no de
espionaje actualmente un equipo
especializado del FBI revisa los restos
del globo que fue derribado por las
fuerzas aéreas de Estados Unidos y que
cayeron frente a las costas de Carolina
del Sur
para analizar la masa profundidad de la
repercusiones de este hecho en las
relaciones china Estados Unidos hacemos
contacto con el doctor Gonzalo Paz
profesor de la Universidad de Georgetown
en Washington DC Dr paz Gracias por
aceptar esta invitación y empiezo por
preguntarle fue realmente un error de
cálculo por parte del gobierno de
chimpín lo ocurrido con este globo
Creo que todavía no tenemos la
suficiente información y formación
confiable hay varias hipótesis puede
haber sido un accidente Aunque ha habido
reportes de que por lo menos en cuatro
oportunidades anteriormente tres durante
el gobierno del presidente Trump y otra
vez previo durante el gobierno de del
presidente biden que habría habido otros
globos circulando por el espacio aéreo
de de Estados Unidos pero todavía no
tenemos esa respuesta
disponible de una fuente que que
Confiemos
también admitió que un segundo globo
sobrevoló espacio aéreo latinoamericano
específicamente en Costa Rica y Colombia
Cómo afecta esto las relaciones de china
con esos países y en general con América
Latina
esto es muy llamativo también no sabemos
si fue un globo que pasó por Costa Rica
por Colombia o dos globos diferentes
y vamos que hay menos valores
estratégico para hacer
observaciones e información de
inteligencia sobre estos países pero
América Latina tiene una larga tradición
de defensa
de la soberanía y por tanto Este es un
incidente En todo caso incómodo no hay
también hay que decirlo demasiado
recursos técnicos en América Latina para
determinar la naturaleza de este o estos
globos que habrían circulado de todas
maneras la cercanía con el incidente
norteamericano hace pensar de que son
globos similares
y por lo tanto lo que se hace en el
globo que sí se ha recuperado al haberlo
derribado en Estados Unidos Seguramente
se va a extender esa interpretación a
los otros dos globos
pero de un punto de vista más más
conceptual reitero hay una larga defensa
historia de la defensa de la soberanía
en América Latina Y seguramente Este es
un un incidente que va a dar bastante
tela para cortar
en un escenario hipotético según usted
qué habría ocurrido si la situación
hubiera sido al contrario que un globo
estadounidense hubiera sobrevolado el
espacio aéreo chino
Hola en primer lugar Habría que ver si
lo detectan o no lo detectan el
espionaje es tan viejo como la humanidad
y
aún después de la Guerra Fría el
espionaje ha continuado entre entre
países e incluso Tenemos muchos casos de
espionaje a países amigos conocer sus
intenciones
tener garantías que las cosas que se
dicen son ciertas Esta no es el costado
más glamoroso precisamente de las
relaciones internacionales es una
realidad que existe Y seguramente si
tiene hubiera detectado
un globo que fuera espía seguramente
habría tenido una protesta muy fuerte O
quizá hubiera tomado algún tipo de
medida militar al respecto
agradecemos al doctor Gonzalo paz por su
análisis pasamos Australia donde el
gobierno dijo no a un megaproyecto para
desarrollar una mina de Carbón a diez
kilómetros de la gran Barrera de coral
el conjunto de arrecifes coralíferos más
extenso del mundo según las autoridades
el riesgo de daños son irreversibles
para este ecosistema veamos el informe
de Andrés granadillo
un rechazo a la extracción de Carbón
para proteger la gran Barrera de coral
de Australia
no permitiría que siguiera adelante el
proyecto central queensland tomé esa
decisión porque el riesgo para la gran
Barrera de coral y para Los Arroyos de
agua dulce y las aguas subterráneas
junto a la mina propuesta era
Sencillamente demasiado grande
la gran Barrera de coral genera unos
seis mil millones de dólares de
actividad económica al año y unos 64,000
puestos de trabajo y teniendo en cuenta
los datos científicos que tengo Es
evidente que los riesgos son demasiado
grandes
el proyecto suspendido se trata de una
mina a cielo abierto que habría tenido
capacidad para excavar 10 millones de
toneladas de carbón al año durante 25
años Aunque hay voces en contra de
cualquier otro proyecto cercano a la
gran Barrera de coral la ministra dejó
abierta la puerta para decidir si
permite o no algún proyecto
su señoría se ha referido a otro
proyecto
marcada decisión que presente caso por
caso Según la ley y según la ciencia
disponible
esta es la primera vez que Australia
rechaza un proyecto de explotación de
carbón amparada en la ley ambiental del
país oceánico estas fueron las promesas
de campaña del actual Primer Ministro
Anthony albanés quien asumió en 2022 ya
había prometido que lucharía contra el
cambio climático y protegería el medio
ambiente desde 2016 la gran Barrera ha
sufrido cuatro blanqueos masivos de
corales por efectos vinculados a la
crisis climática lo que supone un
peligro para este patrimonio de la
humanidad
Nos dirigimos a filipinas el segundo
productor de piña en el mundo por detrás
de Costa Rica además de ser una de las
frutas más consumidas en este país
asiático la piña ha venido cobrando
fuerza en la industria de la moda ya que
el material que resulta reciclaje de sus
fibras es usado para la industria textil
es una fruta como ninguna otra con sus
Espinas protectoras y su pulpa ácida
disfrutada en todo el mundo la piña es
un alimento básico en Filipinas gratis
filipinas es un productor líder del
codiciado cultivo
y esta plantación cubre 26.000 hectáreas
Raúl está a cargo de la cosecha durante
todo el año y supervisa 700 personas
para recolectar más de 2.500 toneladas
de piña al día
algunos de ellos exportan inmediatamente
al extranjero
Y otros se quedan aquí en Filipinas
una planta de piña producirá solo una o
dos frutas entonces después de la
cosecha las plantas se desechan para dar
paso a la próxima generación
pero aquí nada se desperdicia sobre este
principio un nuevo negocio está
prosperando el reciclaje de sus fibras
en la industria textil Isaías macarelli
produce hasta 200 kilos al día de esta
fibra natural una vez seco este material
altamente resistente se transporta
Europa y se convierte en cuero vegano
ahora visto en algunas de las pasarelas
más glamorosas del mundo un mercado
floreciente valorado en casi 200
millones de euros y un pino estas fibras
se convierten en zapatos bolsos y
carteras vendidos por Nike Zara hubos y
otros estoy orgulloso de ver todo esto
hecho 100% de piña filipina en cuanto a
las frutas muchas se quedan en el campo
a veces se venden en las esquinas otras
transformadas en dulces bizcochos jugos
y acompañando manjares inesperados como
las sardinas de la plantación a la
cocina la piña genera más de 2 millones
de empleos en todo filipinas y para
cerrar las dejo algunos datos algunas de
las montañas más altas del mundo se
encuentran en Asia Aquí les presentamos
cinco en primer lugar se encuentra el
Monte Everest que tiene el pico más alto
del mundo a 8.848 metros sobre el nivel
del mar y está ubicado en la frontera
nepal y la región Autónoma china del
Tíbet le sigue el k2 que tiene su pico a
8.611 metros sobre el nivel del mar y
está ubicado en la frontera entre
Pakistán y China En tercer lugar se
sitúa el cancha en junga con
8.586 metros sobre el nivel del mar y se
encuentra ubicado en la frontera entre
nepal e India le sigue el lotze que
tiene su pico a 8.516 metros sobre el
nivel del mar y está ubicado en la
frontera entre nepal y china en el
quinto lugar se sitúa el monte macalu
con una altura de 8.485 metros sobre el
nivel del mar y está ubicado también
entre la frontera de nepal y China
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es hacia Muchas gracias por acompañarlos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]